and like with women leaving again this
is such a broad subject so I'm not I'm
not on about just cheating by the way
yeah
um but yeah one off it's like
I get and understand why men do like
cheese yeah and go for younger women
well what out of it it's actually not
such a broad thing though well men don't
typically leave for younger women they
don't even leave no they're just gonna
cheat and say they want to change but
women cheat in their own way I mean I
think personally I think that sex is to
to men as attention is to women
so I think women need attention like
like men need sex but women are never
expected to close off their social media
yeah yeah but men are expected to stop
having sex with other girls how's that
fair but women can post ass pics on
their Instagram
nobody can touch it right it's like
advertising I mean I was even looking at
I was like okay
imagine okay team Selena by the way
okay I don't know about the Selena Haley
whatever I don't I don't care what I was
looking at was her Instagram I was like
she's married to a world famous pop star
yeah and I know she's a model right but
he's a girl at that point but he's he's
got groupies yeah and he's also very
religious apparently I don't know what's
going on so it's like you're married
married to a world famous pop star and
you still got
look at look at the booty one look at it
yeah look at that yeah okay and the
funny thing is he comments on it as well
so it's bizarre as long as he's okay
with it he's like oh my God yeah but
would she be okay with it if we
commenting under somebody else's post no
would she be okay I think it works one
of two ways like you can't you can't
take one side just because one's a
female and then you're not fat the other
side like true pick your own battles all
all the same but don't don't come at the
man for cheating if she's gonna put it
out there as if she's gonna cheat as
well well interesting then you say that
well I just think of it as like like
mating strategies like women want to get
attention from high status men that's
Instagram
men want to screw as many people as
possible so like how many I don't know
anyone that got married and closed their
Instagram I don't know anyone that did
it like my age anyway actually I told
you're right so yeah so I'm saying
modern women are shitty ones why would
she close your Instagram I don't
understand that because it's advertising
[Laughter]
[Music]
You could argue Justin Bieber's job is
to screw groupies on tour
the model what it's different he's not
he's not a model right so I do get what
you're saying this is the world famous
pop star the singer world famous pop
stars to do they screw groupies on the
tour
bro's oldest time
of the job yeah it is
that's Chris Brown do on snake come on
yeah yeah and you know you can just tell
she would have none of that if he was
doing that yeah but it's like we're in
the society where men aren't told they
can do that they're controlling if they
tell a girl to close her Instagram but
women immediately want you to stop
sleeping with other girls and you can
tell like I know so many people in
relationships who've told people
unfollow her stop liking her photos I
know get rid of her but if you do it to
a man or if you're in a relationship
with another guy and you tell her not to
do that you are the bad person well
you've got to be careful it goes one or
two like you have to look see now I
think that's a standard respect thing
but if you're gonna do one way and not
accept it backwards yeah but there's
different hold on hold on this might be
controversial but I feel like there are
different
um
there are different reasons and there's
people with different circumstances for
example if there was if you was dating
someone and she was for example like a
content creator or something and she had
she was in you know Instagram engagement
groups so if she was an engagement group
in an engagement group There are rules
you have to like everyone's photo to
help each other with the algorithm right
so would you then turn around to your
girlfriend and say to her I don't want
you liking pictures of other guys the
standard person isn't honestly like I'm
not famous
I'm just saying would a good wife argue
with him when he asks that and say well
but my Instagram grouper would she just
say okay whatever you say honey yeah in
a really traditional setup she she would
give it up probably yeah you know if
she's making six figures well regardless
regardless of if he's making six figures
she should be like listen you know we're
married now that is I've made this
commitment in the in the eyes of the
Lord exactly and in the eyes of God so
that's more important to me than having
an Instagram
okay so I have a question why does he
have to be making six figures to have to
be listened to and do you have the same
energy if a woman's Med does she is she
if she's average looking does she not is
she not able to ask for loyalty
um that's a good question but you know
she's average looking so why why does
she get to ask for that yeah
I don't know I don't I don't really know
how to answer that because I just feel
like
women do definitely look at Men's
financial status and we can sit here and
argue about that all the time but at the
end of the day there is survival and
women would always try to go with
someone above her level or at least on
her level she will never go low so you
said six figures
that's 10 a month no I know I was just
trying to be funny there but like
um no but I'm just saying like
realistically she will always go above
or on the same level so she's never
gonna go low so financial status does
get looked at and that is actually how
men earn respect from women I feel like
it's one of the ways that if you want to
earn respect from a woman you need to do
that you need to be able to bank yeah no
bro no brokies
how much does he have to make what about
an average guy
um
I don't know I don't know what the
average salary here is what is it like
40 30 depends on your age so like 25
year olds gonna be earning like 35 000.
all right which in London isn't going to
be very much in in the standards of
learning six figures
and then it's on it's unfair to expect
that off someone
you've got the average you've got the
average UK wage though which is probably
like it's going to be weighted higher in
London yeah yeah because you've got
extremities you've got you know if
you're looking at the mean it's going to
be taking both things does the man
expect us to be top 10 20 30 of beauty
no
but why should they not if we're
expecting them to be in the highway I
think they do want that yeah they might
want it but they're not they're not
going to hold out for it because most
guys are quite thirsty do you know what
I mean we'll talk about this the other
obviously the other night most guys are
quite thirsty
they're gonna take what they could get
you know oh oh yeah I mean that's a good
point it's a good point have you heard
the husband's store analogy no oh
there's like I hope I say this right
there's like a husband store analogy in
the manosphere okay and basically every
every store or every floor
is a different set of husbands okay and
you go up before
um then the only rules you can't go back
down so there's five floors total and
you can go up but you can't go down so
the first floor is guys that love kids
yeah and our and our loyal to you oh
sweet and so the women go to the first
floor so they go to the first floor and
they say you know what I want more I
wanna I wanna go up so they go to the
second floor and then they should do one
no no no no it gets better it gets
better so these guys love kids they're
loyal and they're hot oh they're sexy
yeah
well
what's on the next floor okay then they
get just curious yeah yeah so they go
what's what's next curiosity they say
they say okay the next floor these guys
are hot they make 70 000 a year they
love kids and they're loyal
but she's on the third floor and she's
like well what's what what's up what's
on the next floor and so back at it then
she goes next they make six figures
love kids loyal
everything but she wants to go to the
fifth floor and on the fifth [__] to us
on Facebook all the husbands are sold
out
I love the dogs because die alone
I mean so so that to make it fair they
did a wife score a wife score right so
on the first floor there's women good
sex loyal
sixes and they never found out was it
what was on the second floor
I think modern day woman no offense and
I know I'm a woman but are super like
materialistic I don't agree
I love most of my friends but I know if
they were given the opportunity to go
with someone who aren't like over a
million they will take it they would
take it and they'll cheat on the passion
that they love and they feel committed
to and that's such an issue well they
cheat for money I mean the words yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
is seen as normal now to cheat and it's
seen as normal to like be like oh yeah
but he's better yeah and they won't why
why not just fight them through your
family better because he have money
exactly why is it why is that important
exactly that's why guys shouldn't get
married because
that's the dynamic but you're as a guy
you're entering into a contract with
somebody when that is the dynamic that's
going on in society and that's very
problematic because you're you're
basically marrying into it's like it's
like buying a house that it's got loads
of faults with the house and you're
going to have loads of money to pay
further down the line it's like you're
buying you're getting into a contract
with somebody who is being influenced by
the society that's basically saying to
you there's always going to be better
there's always your and not only is that
always going to be better but you
deserve better you know you go girl you
go on to the next dude just one more and
more yes
why is that worth it my Grandma had 13
kids for a fireman and she submitted to
him and that's that's the thing like
modern that's a good job but that's
beautiful that is what it should be it
was an average salary back then and so
I'm I'm just saying like you know what
is this generation this generation is
just getting worse but but money
shouldn't be the end
and it is what it is if you feel that
emotionally attached to someone like if
you're someone like me that doesn't want
to particularly get married if you feel
that emotionally attached that you're
willing to get married you should not
just up and leave because someone else
has more money or someone else maybe is
more attractive like it should be all
taken as I've committed to this person
for a reason there was something there
unless there's something a lot deeper
going on like abuse or or something it's
a lot deeper and it's a lot more complex
if it's something as simple as that
person earns more I'm gonna go with them
so do you think that the woman so would
you say you think that the woman should
stick it out basically even if there is
like a period of suffering not
necessarily stick out but don't worry
say this man that she's with is like
literally not hardly making any money
they are really struggling like times
are really tough for her and do you
think that she should just stay and
stick it out or do you think she should
want better for herself
can I can I just read something really
quick okay all right
um
I take you for my lawfully wedded
husband
for richer or for poor and sickness and
health till death do us part if you
believe in leaving the second there's a
rough patch you might get married
oh that blood was that's all Boomer
stuff that Bible [__]
oh my God but the whole point is like if
if you believe in divorce then why get
married there's no point just be in a
relationship because you're not a wife I
mean you you getting married and then
you think oh I'm gonna divorce one day I
just wanted to answer prenups though
because it's like well I don't think
anyone wants to get divorced when they
get married they think it's forever but
I think things happen yeah and you have
to be realistic that but that's I'm not
saying that maybe you marry someone and
in the beginning it's all good and then
suddenly when you get married he might
lose his money and then leave him no I
don't agree with that but I feel like
yeah I feel like you should still stay
with that person but if there's no
progress there's no sign of him you know
working hard or trying or trying to get
back to that level that he was at
for poor
yeah and sickness and in health until
death do us anyways that's it this is
what Massey the the author of the
rational male who talks a lot about this
kind of these kind of intergender
Dynamics he talks about the burden of
performance on men and that's exactly
what you're talking about then there's
always this there's this burden of
performance on men it's like okay well
he could have a rough patch but if he
doesn't shape up after two years you
know she's gonna be like thinking well
hang on what's going on which is
all right I understand why you would say
that but that is contrary to what Pearl
right now because the agreement is For
Better or Worse for sicker and poorer
because it could be he's got some
underlying issue like he's got maybe
some underlying like like depression or
something like that he's trying to deal
with some trouble and he's not working
he's not pushing himself to the degree
because of that but you know the the
woman who disregards that could just say
well solid you know I'm going to go for
Steve over here because he's making six
figures so I have a question so the same
way you believe that
um if he's not making more money or
working or whatever you should leave
should he leave her if she gets fat
[Laughter]
I'm just asking yes
um
I think he's he's allowed to to bring it
up yeah for sure
we're going to give her some chance you
know to get in the gym and she got like
three months six months oh well no
because she's not gonna leave him like
if the woman is like in that situation
she's not we're not saying the woman's
just gonna go right oh you're not
working for three months off I go like
it's not gonna happen like that she's
obviously gonna stick it out she's gonna
try and help especially if you've got
kids it's different like she may not be
able to go back to work they may have to
find alternative ways of surviving I
don't know it's very difficult but she's
not going to leave straight away it's
it's you know over a few years three
four years maybe I don't know
um and in the same yeah same energy for
for the man as well if the woman's
completely let herself go and you know
she's not taking care of herself forget
the man it's not even good for you as a
woman forget him like it's about you
like you want to be able to look
yourself in the mirror and feel
confident and happy and you know
comfortable in your skin so go out and
do something about it so I yeah but he
have to make sure you you get like some
compliments about it yeah so he can make
you feel better but are you gonna give
him the same compliments if he has no
job oh yeah yeah you know what I mean
yeah
I have a question do you January I'm
gonna help him do you genuinely think
most women nicely ask or do you think
most women nag let's just
window
s baby I'm so happy you didn't you
didn't do that thing I asked you to do
last week yeah very hot
the woman condition yeah
it could be a way but the female
condition is very different to a man as
well like we we do like to
offensive picket things yeah whereas a
man will be very much more upfront about
it and if they have an issue with
something most of the time most of the
time not all men I I know not all men
are quite as straightforward as that but
most men will just say it as it is
whereas women will sugarcoat things
it makes it more complicated so if you
can't take it don't give it
my opinion on it is as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible